now as to the question of what does that
method actually mean
i mean uh what is the meaning of it we
need to now turn over the page and have
a look at an actual data set okay
oh no sorry i tell a lie um oh yeah no
we can do it yeah let's go to this
actual data set okay here we go
so we're going to consider this data and
its line of best fit right
now can you see this is the data set i
showed you before so it's got those
eight data points and i've got four
above and four below okay now if you've
got two colors here two colors of pens
this will be a lot easier um i can cheat
because i have every color um here
what we're going to do is show
where all of these data points deviate
from our line of best fit now to
indicate the differences right i'm going
to show all my ones above the line of
best fit in
red i guess and all the ones below in
blue just so i can signify for myself
that there's differences here okay so
with my red color i'm going to say well
look at this data point can you see
that's where it it sorry it's not very
uh strong that's where it deviates from
the line of best fit it's a vertical
line right that's the difference okay
and then i've got another data point
again this is also
up above
this one in here is pretty close
and then i've got one last one over here
like so you can use a ruler for this
because the more accurate you'll be the
better okay these are all my data points
above and then i'm going to switch over
to blue to do my data points beneath the
line of best fear so you can see them
here
here
here
and over here
okay
now what i want to do
or rather what the correlation
coefficient does you know how squaring
and square root business
what it does is not only standardize but
it also says the further away you are
the more of a difference you make so
this is sort of to do connected to the
idea of an outlier it really throws you
out by a far distance okay
so what we do is we don't actually add
up just those distances right we
actually add up the square of those
distances and we want to try and
minimize those so if you can imagine
let's go back to this first one right i
want to draw a square
that has that side length so you can
actually do this attached to that side
right i'm going to draw a square that
looks like this
can you see i know mine's approximately
you'll be able to do a better job than i
will but this square now represents how
far away are you as a difference right
and then you can see there's one
underneath here again i'm going to draw
i'm going to eyeball this it's going to
be roughly there i'd say
there
and there if you really want to be very
neat you can sort of like color this in
and what you can see i'm getting here
is
a representation if i add all of these
up
of again how much we collectively
deviate from this line of best fit and
we're going to continue this right in
order to do all these quests you can see
all my lines above because of where
these differences go your squares on top
they all draw to the left okay so i'm
going to draw another one like so
these squares go in that direction
this one's a small one
and then i've got one more over here
square
like so
and again like i said if you want to
make it a little more obvious you can
sort of color it in like so just so you
can see what's happening
so these are all my differences above
and then what i want to do is position
my line of best fit so that all of my
differences below kind of cancel out
right so here's another square
there's this one going to go somewhere
about there
sorry that's a bit messy i'm trying to
do this in a timely fashion for you guys
this is the biggest square that i can
see over here
and just like before i'm going to color
these
now
the reason why this is important is
actually because this picture will
answer two questions for us number one
it will answer this question of what
does it actually mean this correlation
coefficient what is it calculating and
number two it will actually give us a
technical definition for the line of
best fit the line of best fit like even
the name it's like oh it fits roughly
right but actually the technical
definition for it is a very long name
which some of you might have encountered
before
but this is the meaning of it okay
so i'll come back to this picture in a
second if you're still drawing but i'm
going to turn back to the original side
of my piece of paper and i'm now going
to give you the definition technically
speaking for the line of best fit
the line of best fit is actually called
the least
squares
regression line
that's a mouthful you can see why we
call it colloquially a line of best fit
because it's much easier to say however
the least squares regression line is a
much better definition
the least squares regression line is
that line that takes all those squares
that we drew before those eight squares
and it makes them as small as possible
and that's why it's literally called the
least squares we're trying to
minimize
the difference
that we get from all of those squares
or you might say the the difference sum
of all the squares
because each of those squares when you
add them all up represent more and more
differences and they kind of like stack
up on each other right so calling it the
least squares is there's some line that
if you position it there the squares in
total add up to the smallest amount
so that's the least squares part when
you have a look at this next part of the
definition or the name regression right
now there's a word in english that we
use a lot more frequently than
regression which actually kind of gives
you i think the key to understanding
what regression is all about
statistically anyway um you know when
you do something and then you're like in
your mind you go back to when you did
that you wish you hadn't had done it
what do we call that we call that regret
right when you regret something
is when you go back in your mind to that
thing and wish you hadn't have done it
right now the idea of regression you can
see even the word and its similarity
tells you these things are connected the
word regression or regress is to go back
to
and that's what this least squares is
about can you see that those squares
they measure for you the distance back
to that line of best fit so the least
squares regression line is trying to say
when you regress back to that line of
best fit which is the line that will
make those squares the smallest so the
least squares part means can we minimize
and the regression part means like what
are you minimizing and the answer is
that distance those differences all of
those squares added up together to get
you back to the line so even though
this is a very long awkward definition
once you understand what each of the
individual pieces are you can see it
literally just means what it says
so you can see now we're ready kind of
to finish out everything and tie this on
a knee bow um what is like the line of
best fit what does it mean why does the
line of best fit fit best and the answer
is because it minimizes those squares it
minimizes those dis differences whoopsie
daisy
minimizes
the differences or the
deviations from
that line
and it represents that with the areas of
those squares added up together and
that's why it's called the least squares
regression line
what is the correlation coefficient
measure well you can see on a normal
data set unless you've got like
perfectly along the line you're going to
have some deviations you're going to
have some differences these squares here
are going to add up to something that
isn't zero so what is the correlation
coefficient measure it's well how much
are those squares deviating it's what or
how much
are
all the deviations
totaling to
and so you can see in a single number it
captures all of those different like uh
added up together the bigger those
squares are if you can imagine you know
having some not very accurately drawn
line of best fit like so if i had some
uh
you know here's a distance here and you
can see the square that i would get out
of this would be enormous it's bigger
than all the other squares put together
that i put on there so this here would
have this huge correlation
or rather a small correlation because
it's not correlating very well and
that's probably the trickiest part of
this actually that we would say you
might remember when we standardized
this idea here we go from negative one
all the way to one and zero is a small
correlation uh it's no correlation but
it comes from having very large
differences so big squares means small
correlations so we would say that those
are inversely proportional to each other
and this gives us our sort of last bit
that we were missing what does the
method actually mean well just see the
least squares regression line what we
are trying to define is from that least
squares regression line tell me the
magnitude of all those squares can we
quantify it in a standardized way and
that's all r is about and by the way
that was my that's my theory when we say
like oh why is it r why is it that
letter i think it has to do with
regression but you know a lot of things
are like that why is gradient m why is
the unknown x there is just some
mysteries in maths because of the
history of how we came up with these
things
so i hope that makes sense it's a big
concept as you can see but once you sort
of tease out this formula and all the
bits of it it actually i think makes a
lot of sense and you don't have to fret
about memorizing this awkward thing or
even using it you know you might have to
do this in an assignment where you can
refer to it but in the context of an
exam you wouldn't be under the pressure
of tabulating all of that data